so let's continue that college
discussion for a minute I haven't had
that in a while so let me tell you all
for MZ kids went to the University of
Tennessee all three Ramsay kids there's
not a straight one
all three Ramsay kids one of my sons in
law graduated from there too that's what
the runs through my head okay but all
three of my children went to the
University of Tennessee and in state
school okay they did not go across state
lines and pay triple for the exact same
education see if we go to the University
of Kentucky fine school to the
University Alabama fine school
University of Georgia fine school
University of South Carolina fine school
nothing wrong with them we can have
discussions about football later but I'm
talking about the academics okay there's
nothing wrong with any of those colleges
you graduate from any one of those
colleges universities you did great glad
you went there you didn't get a
substandard education okay but if you
move across the state line and go to the
University of Georgia instead of paying
$12,000 a year you pay $30,000 a year
for basically the same education why
because just because you walked across
state line that's all so there's just no
excuse for that there's no value added
for the extra money spent if you've got
the money laying around and you just
want to buy it as a luxury that's fine I
got a friend his kids all went to Auburn
and he just paid for it he has plenty of
money and they just wanted to go to
Auburn well that's fine I got no issue
with that but I'm talking about people
going into student loan debt because
okay it's just the whining and the
Beagle chasing a rabbit out there the
the man it's amazing
okay so that's thing one the thing -
there's nothing wrong the private
education if you can afford it but I
mean Vanderbilt University is right at
60,000 bucks University of Tennessee is
right at 12,000 now I'm sure that
Vanderbilt
superior academically to the University
of Tennessee in some areas but I am
1000% sure it's not 5x I know this
because I graduated from the University
of Tennessee and people who graduate
from Vanderbilt worked for me so to tell
me that it's worth 5x is kind of
humorous to me again if you've got the
money or you're going on I have a nice
they got a full ride at Vanderbilt as
valedictorian yeah go that's awesome
not mad at Vanderbilt certainly not but
I'm not my kids I'm not paying my kids
were not gonna get free rides ok they
were just normal students and so they
didn't get a free ride on academics or
on athletics or anything else so Ramsey
Dave is gonna be writing a check and so
am I getting more for my money not 5x so
we didn't do that we went to University
of Tennessee
I don't really care where I go it's my
freakin money I choose no III appreciate
you little feelings well you're a
control freak yeah I'm kind of that way
about my kids and my money I want them
to all to win and I'm smarter than you
because I'm older than you I've lived
longer and I've seen stupid in a bag
most of my life and you don't need to be
stupid in a bag you're my kid and so
what I'm saying is this part of our
student loan crisis is not a cost of
college crisis it's a parenting crisis
some of you parents need to put your arm
around the shoulder of your teen and
kick their little butt no you're not
going over there this family cannot
afford that no you're not going into
debt we're not doing that we're gonna
find a way for you to get a good
education and become a smart person a
smarter person without being a stupid
person in the process no I had a girl
call me on here about four months ago
from South Carolina that wanted to go to
Ole Miss
I said why don't you go to South
Carolina why like Ole Miss why do you
want to pay three times as much to go to
Ole Miss as South Carolina you know what
our answer was the houses are pretty in
that town this is why people need
parents no young lady says her father or
her mother who loves her your little
butt is going to South Carolina which is
a fine school or something in that's a
state school here if we don't have any
money now if you've got the money I
don't care where you go do whatever you
want to I'm talking about the one point
six trillion dollars in student loan
debt that's a that's about to be a
bubble that's gonna smack all of us
around in this entire economy because we
didn't tell a bunch of
eighteen-year-olds no we the people have
been stupid we have allowed this to go
on as parents and as taxpayers we're
stupid because in the name of education
we were stupid
it's crazy y'all and not some of these
kids I mean they're in their 20s and
they have legitimate problems I have two
hundred eighty thousand dollars in debt
Dave and I have a degree of a master's
degree in sociology
oh shoot me you know you're a caseworker
for the state making thirty two grand
with two hundred eighty thousand dollars
in debt and no wonder you feel the Bern
because you feel stuck and you think
Bernie is Santa Claus that's why you
feel the Bern as you you're stuck you're
scared to death you're hopeless in
anybody coming along with anything huh
hey I'll take communism I'll take
socialism I'll take Santa Claus I'll
take whoever just get me out of this
dadgum mess that I got into that's what
they're saying they're scared to death
man I don't blame them for being scared
so parents and for God's sakes some of
your school administrators grow some
integrity and some of your school
counselors quit signing all these kids
up for this crap and sending them off to
get this debt you're you
you're complicit - oh by the way
Congress you need to put an end to the
student loan program you need to just
stop it you need to stop it it's a
disaster and it's not necessary
have you ever any of you all remember
economics did you know if you ever take
economics it was a class we had in
college or in some of us had it in high
school
basic economics says this if the supply
exceeds the demand the price goes down
if there's a bazillion houses on the
market and not many people looking for
houses house prices drop you want
college prices to go down let's stem the
demand oh you want the entire population
to be ignorant nope I'm all quit sending
them to colleges they can't afford
that's all I'm gonna do and the colleges
that they can't afford will suddenly get
more affordable what a novel idea I'd
almost be willing to forgive a
percentage of the student loan debt out
there under some kind of a program if we
stopped the current one completely it's
a disaster folks it's a real real
sociological financial economic and
governmental problem it's a real problem
all because no one in our culture had
the backbone to say no to a bunch of
freaking 18 year olds No